whatever was that hip he gave me this
crazy ability he is a meta who can
travel through mirrors oh I got this one
he's a mirror master there's no can stop
us
I'm stuck in a mirror pants make my butt
look big
hey youtubers is Charlie mere master
coming to the flash finally let's break
it down everybody's been asking for him
the last couple years where the hell is
mirror master so here he is this is Sam
Scudder so if you haven't read the
comics there are a couple different
versions of mirror master he is just the
first version he's a metahuman that can
travel through mirrors so you kind of
see the way it works on the TV show in
this trailer here but the mirror
dimension for those either asking about
that is like the space between the
mirrors between reflective surfaces
that's Evan McCullough so they might
work up to that in a future season but
they're not doing mirror dimension on
the TV show yet Sam Scudder is just
gonna be phasing between mirrors between
reflective surfaces like you see him
trap Barry in the mirror here does my
ass look big like you could kind of tell
from the tone of the trailer that's
gonna be a lot of fun but the other big
thing is Jesse quick here in her
trajectory uniform is gonna be training
experience for her so her big thing is
being a little headstrong so I'm
expecting her to get into some trouble
in a really fun way the other character
here this female character is top in the
comics it's a man named Rosco Dillon so
they gender flipped it but his power is
basically inducing vertigo in other
people so I don't know if she's gonna
have powers on the TV show or if she's
just gonna be like a golden glider type
person who maybe get some technology or
something like that
like golden glider in the comics is a
metahuman but on the TV show she had the
gun so just expect a few twists with her
but they have like a Bonnie and Clyde
thing going on and Wentworth Miller is
coming back Captain Cold is gonna be in
the episode for everybody wondering
where he's been so it seems like what's
going on is there's going to be a big
rogue war happening this season so we'll
probably get our first tease of that in
this episode so it sounds like mere
master is gonna be on like one side of
this conflict and Captain Cold is going
to be on the other the title of the
episode is the new Rogues but obviously
we're only on Episode four so I'm
expecting to see a whole bunch of other
new rogues that we haven't seen before
that's typically what they try to do
with each new season is introduce a
bunch of new comic book characters so
just
to see a whole bunch of new rogues this
season but let me know what do you guys
most hype about just like finally seeing
mirror master on screen or the idea of
an all-out rogue war if you didn't read
that that was actually like a specific
part of Geoff Johns run on the flash
we're basically like half of the Rogues
just go after the other half of the rows
it just becomes this big civil war but
the other really important thing is dr.
alchemy what does he have to do with the
rogues fighting each other
so just be on the lookout for him in the
episode and which characters he shows up
with like if he meets up with mirror
master or if he meets up with Captain
Cold it sounds like Captain Cold is
really evil in this timeline because he
will be part of the Legion of Doom on
legends of tomorrow so it might be like
a way more hardcore version of the
character that we haven't seen before
but if you're wondering why Wentworth
Miller isn't around as much this year
it's not that they don't want to do
Captain Cold it's just that he's doing
that Prison Break reunion so I think
they're trying to work him in just a
little bit less but still use them in
really cool ways so get height and there
is a new round of the DC giveaway going
on now all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I know a lot of you have been
asking me about Jay Garrick Mark Hamill
stuff that's been happening Mark Hamill
is coming back to the flash this season
but just because it's super spoilery and
I don't think it's gonna happen til the
mid-season finale I don't want to talk
about it yet we'll talk about it more
when it gets a little bit closer to that
but Mark Hamill is coming back to guest
star on the flash it seems like that's
gonna be episode 9 just like it was last
year like they did the funk Christmas
episode so just expect something really
crazy but just a little bit different so
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening this weekend I have some
Wolverine that I'm going to do some more
guardians of the galaxy - there's some
cool Game of Thrones and there's another
new video that I want to try out in the
next couple of days that I had an idea
for but I don't know exactly when that's
gonna post so I'll just let everybody
know on Twitter and Facebook whenever
I'm posting that but next new video will
be Doctor Strange Illuminati Avengers
infinity war Kevin Feige confirmed that
they're going to be doing Illuminati
stuff so we'll just explain what's going
on and what they've been teasing so it's
gonna be really exciting new outro just
a little bit different why you guys wait
for that next video to post you can
click up top for that low
in trailer again and you can click down
here for the guardians of the galaxy
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight